unter dem machen wir es nicht solange
münch ist bei uns
politikwissenschaftlerin sie ist die
chefin der akademie der politischen
bildung in tutzing
jetzt haben wir dieses beispiel des
klimawandels man hätte corona noch
anführen können man hätte die welt
schuldenkrise anführen können andere
konflikte der welt es ist eine menge
liegen geblieben und es ist wahnsinnig
viel zu tun
würden sie sagen dass man wenn man die
wahl gewinnt nicht zu beneiden ist man
ist nicht zu beneiden aber das geht uns
hier alles so also wir sind ja alle also
unabhängig davon ob wir jetzt das
gestalten müssen oder ob wir nur
gestaltet werden und uns entscheiden
müssen wenn wir wählen also da sitzen
wir tatsächlich alle im selben boot aber
sind tatsächlich diejenigen nicht zu
beneiden die das verantworten müssen und
zwar auch deshalb weil man einerseits
riesengroß die aufgaben sind die vielen
aufgaben dass man das ja auch
international abstimmen muss und wie
verhalten gleichzeitig die bevölkerung
ist einerseits ist umstritten muss es
denn wirklich gleich so die ganz großen
ziele seien so eindeutig ist da die
öffentliche meinung nicht dazu und vor
allem sind nur 1 euro ist nur ein teil
der bevölkerung dann auch bereit die
konsequenzen daraus zu ertragen und dass
man sie wollen sagen und zu wollen und
es mit zu leben also insofern der
künftigen regierung wird es tatsächlich
schwer gemacht weil wir ihr im grunde
dann ja auch durchaus in den rücken
fallen und sagen wir wissen zwar dass
man eigentlich viel tun müsste aber
wirklich wünschen tun was uns nie und
wir tragen sie auch nur bedingt mit wir
sprechen natürlich über die bürger aber
auch über die politiker von denen diese
aufgaben jetzt stehen albrecht von lucke
ist bei uns politikwissenschaftler
publizist autor all dieses bei allen
parteien denkt man eher von lucke dass
diese riesigen aufgaben gesehen werden
aber dass sie in den programmen der
parteien auf ein kleines karo schrumpfen
also das nicht adäquat auch die ideen
und die lösungen in der luft liegen wenn
man die größe diese aufgaben beschreibt
ist es tatsächlich irgendwie im block
und wann fliegt er auf
münchen den punkt schon sehr zustimmen
ich würde es noch zuspitzen es sind eben
zumutung enorme zumutung die sich selbst
die grünen in diesem wahlkampf ja wir
haben uns davor in der sendung erlebt
kaum trauen auszusprechen das war die
bemerkenswerteste runde für mein
verstand wohl sehr offen gefragt wurde
wird auch verzichten notwendig seien und
man wird mit fug und recht sagen konnten
dass der ehrlichste christian lindner
war der sehr deutlich sagen mein projekt
geht nicht über verzicht ich gewählt
alleine nur durch innovation und in
keinster weise irgendwie die
gesellschaftliche frage wie müssen wir
ökonomisch denken wir müssen wir auch
produzieren die müssen wir konsumieren
dies war ganz klar angesprochen dieser
trend den er am klarsten ausspricht wir
sind klar innovationen in der lage haben
die besten ingenieure für uns das
auffinden ja wir finden uns raus wie
andere klassische antwort ist die mir
wachsen uns raus das erklärt ich das ist
die la statt antwort wir erledigen damit
quasi auch gleich noch die verschuldungs
frage denn wir werden aus der krise raus
sagte übrigens nichts wesentlich anderes
hat olaf scholz verheißen das heißt
diese grund antworten sind
erstaunlicherweise übrigens bei all
diesen drei parteien ziemlich ähnlich
und selbst die grünen haben nicht die
große traute gehabt in diesem wahlkampf
weil sie angst vor dem wähler ein stück
haben ja mit ihren 16 cent pro liter
benzin auch hart abgestraft worden und
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen sie haben
angst dieses große gesellschaftliche
projekt wirklich deutlich
auszuformulieren denn und auch zu ende
zu denken zumindest losriss abonnieren
die krise an einem beispiel deutlich
machen die tatsache der umstellung der
automobilindustrie auf e-mobilität her
wird nicht reichen um die klimafrage zu
lösen ist eine hilfe man kann deutlich
sagen es ist ein konjunkturprogramm der
deutschen automobilindustrie die autos
werden dadurch in keinem dort kleiner
wir hätten den rebound effekt ist wird
im zweifel sogar mehr energie sowohl bei
der produktion als auch später beim
verbrauch der autos geht also diese
grundsätzliche frage eines
gesellschaftlichen projekt sie kommen
wir von einer wachstumsideologie fort
die eigentlich hinter all den dingen
steht wenn man nun bewahrung der stadt
punkt spricht die hat keine der parteien
wirklich scharf angesprochen verzicht
ende des wachstums ein anderes erfahrung
eigentlich seit 30 jahren im raum sind
und die letztlich nach antworten drängen
aber es ist genau die diskrepanz es ist
eine bevölkerung die sich zwar
einerseits in worten zum klimaschutz
bekennen dann gleich das privat nicht um
das bei uns ist dagmar rosenfeld
chefredakteuren weltjournal ist in
logischerweise wenn frau rosenfeld diese
wahl so wichtig ist wie
interessanterweise alle sagen dass sie
wichtig ist weil es um großes geht warum
haben dann zwei parteien nur ihre zwei
besten kandidaten nach vorne gestellt
sie spielen auf die grünen und die union
an die aus meiner sicht beide nicht den
den besten kandidaten ins rennen
geschickt haben sondern ihrer partei
intern logik gefolgt sind bei den grünen
war das ganz klar wenn die frau in dem
falle annalena baerbock zieht dann wird
habe ich zurückstecken weil die quote
bei den grünen ein
stück dna ihrer partei ist und bei der
union war es so dass die stärkere partei
darauf oder der stärkere part die cdu
darauf bestanden hat ihren kandidaten
durchzudrücken und ich finde wenn man
sich vorhin die runde die schlussrunde
angeschaut hat und sich gefragt hat wer
von dem ohne zu wissen wer wohin gehört
wer ist wir sind da die
kanzlerkandidaten die drei in der runde
dann hätte ich gesagt klar olaf scholz
souveräner auftritt und markus söder und
christian lindner mit dem stärksten
machtanspruch in dieser runde und den
klarsten aussagen in das heißt es sind
nicht nur die zweitbesten kandidaten
sondern in ihren augen die falschen
kandidaten für dieses amt es standen ja
keine anderen zur disposition insofern
könnte es nur die zweitbesten sein aber
wir lernen ja jetzt auch gerade selbst
zweitplatzierte werden am ende
wahrscheinlich koalitionen bilden kann
wenigstens versuchen markus
feldenkirchen ist bei uns vorm spiegel
hauptstadtstudio öffentlichen auch da
hat man sofort diese begriffe von
erfahrungen und ernst und sogar gravitas
im mund und guckt sich diese runde an
die wir da gerade bei ard und zdf
gesehen haben und da denken sie auch
dass das auf olaf scholz irgendwie
zutrifft
dass der gravitas verkörpert im
vergleich zur teilen seiner konkurrenz
das ist glaube ich so dass bekunden die
bürgerinnen und bürger in den umfragen
von herrn jung und allen anderen
demoskopen immer wieder also an der
ausstrahlung mangels jetzt glaube ich
bei ihm nicht
die ernsthaftigkeit und ob jemand der
größe der aufgabe
die auf die deutsche politik wartet
gewachsen ist die zeigt sich allerdings
nicht in medien coaching und galanten
auftritten sondern im programm und da
muss man sagen ist
sowohl die programmatik was die parteien
anzubieten haben in unterschiedliche
abstufung natürlich als auch wie der
wahlkampf geführt wird
absolut an ein zeichen von unreife von
mangelnder ernsthaftigkeit das
versäumnis der deutschen politik im
umgang mit dem klimawandel der
vergangenen jahrzehnte wurde quasi in
diesem wahlkampf fortgesetzt indem die
größe der aufgabe nicht erkannt wird und
ehrlich gesagt ist sind dann natürlich
auch bürger und wir beobachter
journalisten teil von dem ganzen werden
wir vergleichweise
nebensächlichkeiten eine ganz große
aufmerksamkeit verleihen und das was
wirklich die mega aufgabe unserer
generation ist für die generation die da
kommen den so wenig raum beim essen den
von den dreien dann dennoch persönlich
gefragt trauen sie eben das lösen der
größe diese aufgabe zu
ich traue es ehrlich gesagt allen
theoretisch zu als persönlichkeit der
eine hat mir erfahrungen die andere hat
vielleicht mehr elan armin laschet hat
das talent leute zusammenzuführen sie
sind offenbar alle drei keine begnadeter
wahlkämpfer frau baerbock und herr
laschet haben in diesem wahlkampf so
viel selbstverschuldete fehler gemacht
dass sie und die parteien und dafür wo
die parteien stehen wollen sich wirklich
dreimal den hintern beißen müssen was
dafür chancen verpasst wurden so aber
wenn wenn jetzt einer von denen den
auftrag hätte eine regierung zu bilden
da würde ich zumindest nicht sagen
aufgrund der persönlichkeitsstrukturen
ist jetzt hier
sind die nächsten jahre verloren nein es
geht wirklich um die ambition und ob man
auf die richtigen themen sind und nun
richtig dass ich einmal noch mal kurz
klar machen wir wählen ja nicht den
kanzler wir wählen parteien die am ende
dann im also ein parlament und das
parlament entscheidet am ende über den
kanzler und das ist dem bürger glaube
ich auch klar weshalb es durchaus sein
kann das ist jetzt noch mal sehr eng
wird zwischen spd und cdu am sonntag
politbarometer haben wir gerade gehört
die spd bei 25 die cdu bei
23 das heißt es könnte ein richtig enges
rennen werden eben weil die menschen
glauben sie unterscheiden zwischen der
person und der partei das glaube ich da
bin ich mir eben nicht so sicher weil
wenn man sich die berichterstattung auch
an guckt oder wie wir hier jetzt gerade
wieder sprechen gesprächen über die
personen und die wahlkämpfe sind in den
vergangenen jahren haben sich immer mehr
personalisierte sieht man ja auch bei
landtagswahlen wo die minister
amtierenden ministerpräsidenten oder
ministerpräsidentin gewählt werden und
am ende wird ob die aufgaben die
anstehen bewältigt werden hängen von
koalition tatsächlich ab und eine lehre
ist doch wir haben gesehen rot grün
damals hat nachher das unmögliche
eigentlich geschafft was man niemals von
dieser koalition erwartet hätte wir sind
mit rot-grün außenpolitisch erwachsen
geworden es war der erste kriegseinsatz
der bundeswehr denen eine pazifistische
grün bestimmte partei möglich gemacht
hat oder mit ermöglicht hat und es waren
die hartz reformen die
das land ja massiv verändert haben wie
ich finde auch zum guten die man einer
spd im vorfeld nie zugetraut hätten
damals sehr holprigen start das war ja
eine katastrophe diese anfänge also
insofern es sind auch nicht nur die
parteien oder nicht nur die kandidaten
nicht nur die programme wie sie gesagt
haben das ist schlicht ein ergreifendes
auch hineinwachsen in diese positionen
aber die frage ist natürlich wie viel
zeit hat man dann auch um
hineinzuwachsen ich wollte eine frage zu
diesem inhalte versus personen eben noch
mal stellen bei den grünen wird auch die
fehler natürlich dieser
spitzenkandidatin annalena baerbock
immer verwiesen auf der anderen heute
haben sie das gute argument gebracht zu
sagen wie groß ist denn eigentlich die
veränderungsbereitschaft der menschen in
diesem land also werden die grünen auch
dafür bestraft dass die menschen zwar
sagen oh also klimaschutz ganz schön
wichtig aber ich möchte jetzt nicht die
anführerin einer revolution in meinem
leben sei also meines erachtens ist es
das problem der grünen dass es erstens
möglich ist zu sagen ich interessiere
mich ja für klimapolitik ich möchte ja
nicht abwählen es gibt inzwischen
schlicht ergreifend andere parteien dies
ja ein bisschen komfortabler einem
anbeten die sagen okay doch auch mit
innovation ich muss mich doch nicht
ändern also das hat sich doch deutlich
verändert gegenüber früheren
bundestagswahlen wo im grunde die grünen
doch weitgehend das monopol auf das
thema klimaschutz politik und
umweltpolitik hatten und jetzt kann
nicht mehr unseren größeren portfolio
raussuchen das wo es vielleicht nicht
ganz so weh tut ich glaube wir erleben
allerdings in der akzeptanz von seiner
ambitionierten reformen und einem
ambitionierten klimaschutz wirklich eine
riesen diskrepanz zwischen den
generationen in deutschland wir haben
bei der wahl jetzt am sonntag ist erste
mal dass 38 prozent der wählerinnen und
wähler über 60 sind
der reform dran weil es da auch wirklich
um ihre langfristige zukunft geht ist
naturgemäß bei den jüngeren größer das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat noch mal in
einem entscheidenden urteil das
festgehalten was ehrlich gesagt auch
ohne dieses urteil klar sein müsste dass
es beim klimaschutz um zukunfts und
freiheitsrechte künftiger generationen
geht und deshalb ist es glaube ich also
wirklich ungerecht dass die jugend auch
einen so kleinen teil unseres wahlvolks
abbildet und eine pragmatische vorschlag
jetzt mal eine absenkung des wahlalters
auf mindestens 16 jahre das ist gerade
vor diesem hintergrund wirklich höchste
trotzdem 4% jeder sind 31 oder richtiger
schritt selbst wenn er von lucke die die
klimaschützer sagen oder das
klimaprogramm der grünen nicht reicht um
diese klimaziele zu erreichen die wir
uns mit paris gestellt haben und die ja
nun irgendwie auch bei 15 grad zählt nun
auch gesetz geworden sind noch durch die
große koalition
mit dem neuen umwelt bundes umweltschutz
gesetzt
was heißt dass das heißt dass sich
parteien tatsächlich wenn sich nicht mal
die grünen trauen zu formulieren sie
haben das ausgeführt und was im grunde
genommen auf uns zukommt und zu
kritisieren ist und wieso dieses ziel
nicht erreichen was bedeutet es dann
automatisch für das was sich der wähler
da rausnehmen musste ja zunächst mal
bedeutet es meinem eindruck nach
ohne nämlich gefahr zu laufen immer den
grünen den vorwurf zu machen die dann
auch mit abstand am meisten fordern das
muss man an dieser stelle deutlich sagen
dass offensichtlich schon dass zu wenige
so wenig attraktiv ist ohne dass ich
jetzt die ganzen fehler von annalena
baerbock nicht auch zur kenntnis nehmen
müsste das ist ganz klar all diese
katastrophale performance der
spitzenkandidatin hat den grünen eminent
geschadet also ich glaube tatsächlich
dass wird für die grünen mit der
härteste einschlag sein werden ja vor
allem zwei große verlierer am sonntag
erleben das werden die grünen seien und
in unterschiedlicher breite cdu/csu wenn
herr laschet hinter herrn scholz landet
ist das ein gau und er kann nur hoffen
dass er vielleicht die nasenspitze noch
vor scholz ist dann wäre es trotzdem mit
abstand das schlechteste ergebnis der
cdu csu das sind also mit sicherheit
zwei große verlierer geschichtenlieder
bilanzieren müssen aber das problem hin
verlierer sind nur mit blick auf die
umfragen liegen union
und das problem wird sein nicht die
umfragen sind das entscheiden oder auch
nicht der letzte da setzt der
wahlergebnis entscheidende wird das sein
was für eine grüne partei erreichbar war
und das wird weit mehr gewesen sein als
die 15 prozent die am ende rauskommen
das ist doch ganz klar der maßstab der
beginnt die grünen selber an grünwoldt
grünen soll auch die grünen die grünen
wollten kann das ist ein titel na ja ich
wollte ist kanzler sie wollten kanzler
werden sie wollten die spd als die
partei der linken mitte ablösen das ist
auch ein reelles ziel gewesen daran sind
sie gescheitert das muss man leider auch
den fehlern von der burg zu schreiben
nur das problem ist einfach die
versuchung eines großen teils der
bevölkerung den bekundungen
beispielsweise eines olaf scholz sofort
folge zu leisten der nicht gerade bis
dato bis vor dem 1 markus feldenkirchen
zurecht angesprochen vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht urteil nicht
als ein großer kämpfer in der kleine
getreten ist das wird man wahrlich nicht
behaupten der wahl plötzlich auftrat als
hätte er den klimaschutz tun aber das
eben nicht mit zumutung verbindet
sondern sagt wir machen klimapolitik als
industriepolitik übrigens ganz normal
asche diese versuchung ist so groß dass
die wählerschaft natürlich gesagt
vernehmenden über das leichte angebot
und verzichten wenigen zumutung die
grünen sparen es zu zitieren rosenfeld
mit dem satz wer auf dem land grün wählt
kann seine autoschlüssel vielleicht mit
in die wahlurne werfen also das sagt
ausgerechnet der vertreter der partei
die auf co2 bepreisung setzt was ist das
anderes als populismus als ignoranz als
naja es ist wahlkampf
haben ja auch neben seine partei stellen
aber wir reden ja jetzt schon über die
klimapolitik der zukunft ich würde gern
mal ganz kurz ein blick auf die
klimapolitik schon von jetzt werfen um
zu zeigen was da an herausforderung
ansteht und was da auch an kosten an
steht also in diesem klimaschutzgesetz
sind ja co2-emission jährliche für alle
sektoren in diesem land erlassen worden
die nicht überschritten werden dürfen
wenn sie überschritten werden da gibt es
eine selbstverpflichtung der
bundesregierung dann wird man ein
sofortprogramm auflegen um das für die
kommenden jahre abzuschaffen und ein
expertenrat ein klima experten rat hat
über diese sofortprogramme zu befinden
im vergangenen jahr hat haben alle
sektoren bis auf einen die ziele nicht
gerissen weil wir im vergangenen jahr
aber auch ein ziemlich lahm gelegt das
land gewesen mit corona so der geburten
gebäudesektor hat aber das ziel gerissen
daraufhin hat dann zuständig sind
innenministerium wirtschaftsministerium
die haben ein sofortprogramm vorgelegt
kosten 5,6 milliarden euro das haben die
diesen klimarat vorgestellt der hat es
für nicht ausreichend empfunden und
gesagt da ändert sich viel zu spät etwas
jetzt ist nach gelegt worden am mittwoch
hatte das kabinett ein programm von elf
milliarden euro für gebäudesanierung
verabschiedet als reaktion weil man da
die ziele gerissen hat in den nächsten
jahren ist es wahrscheinlich ich dass
auch andere sektoren die ziele reißen
wenn wir immer mit solchen
sofortprogramm reagieren ist das eine
notstands ad hoc politik und ich frage
mich wo es die langfristige strategie
also das was jetzt schon da ist es eine
wahnsinnige herausforderung und dann
jetzt noch einmal dazu rücken darüber zu
reden was noch obendrauf gelegt werden
soll mir fehlt die fantasie wie das
bezahlt werden soll und wie das vor
allem akzeptiert werden soll in der
gesellschaft wenn man die reaktionen auf
den benzinpreis schon gesehen los corona
+4 hund also die 400 milliarden schulden
die wir da haben plus überhaupt unsere
verschuldung im land und in europa das
ist markus feldenkirchen man könnte
sagen so groß wie die deutsche einheit
so wird es auch publiziert dass eine
billion euro darin die auf die uhr
kommen und zwar für den klimaschutz den
wir organisieren wollen und den wandel
der gesellschaft aber auch um zu
bezahlen welche klima schäden
angerichtet werden eine billion euro
dies ist so groß wie die deutsche
einheit nur dass eben wie die kassen
schon leer sind ist diesmal alle
betrifft und helmut kohl nicht da ist
also helmut kohl gehört zu den figuren
wie auch andere seine vorgänger die eben
keinen aktiven klimaschutz betrieben
haben keinen ambitionierten weshalb wir
jetzt in diesem dilemma stecken ich
glaube aber alles geld was wir zur
eindämmung der erderwärmung jetzt
investieren dass das best investierte
geld ist mindestens so gut investiert
wie in die deutsche einheit weil
ansonsten all die politischen punkte die
wir für bedeutsam halten wie unser
rentensystem eintritt weil wir unser
renteneintrittsalter ist wie unsere
schulbildung aussieht irgendwann keine
rolle mehr spielen weil wenn wir den
punkt erreichen wo die sogenannten
klimatischen kipp punkte erreicht sind
wo prozesse in gang geraten die
unkontrollierbar sind und die große
teile unseres planeten vernichten können
dann braucht man über all das worüber
wir auch in diesen runden immer
diskutiert haben irgendwann nicht mehr
diskutieren und insofern jede
kreativität und jede bereitschaft dafür
auch geld klar sind investiert
aufzubringen ist glaube ich sehr sehr
sinnvoll wenn ihr rest in ordnung in
diesem land wäre wäre das ja auch schon
eine sache aber du hast es selber
angesprochen das rentensystem
demografischer wandel wollen wir noch
leben dazu und
inklusive der frage ob wir alle
eigentlich glauben dass jetzt
tatsächlich es nur sechs monate braucht
um windräder zu planen und nicht mehr
sehen machen wir gleich wir begrüßen an
der stelle zwingend und unbedingt
matthias jung der chef der
forschungsgruppe wahlen
toll dass sie heute bei uns sind herr
jungen sie haben mit neuen zahlen des
politbarometers irgendwie schon die
nacht beschwingt
fragen wir vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen größer die themen sind die
wichtig für eine wahlentscheidung war
diese wahl ist diese wahl eine
themenwahl eine klima war was sagt die
wahlforschung wir haben ganz generell
immer die situation dass drei faktoren 1
wahlergebnis bestimmen das ist einmal
natürlich auch die themen wobei in der
breite der bevölkerung nur zugespitzte
gruppe positionen eigentlich ankommen
beim den wählerinnen und wähler wir
haben als zweites natürlich auch die
person wobei ich da ein bisschen
skeptisch bin dass wir heute eine viel
größere personalisierung haben als das
bei früheren
bundestagswahlen gewesen ist denken sie
an adenauer ein brand das waren alles
sehr stark
personalisierte wahlentscheidung auch
die entscheidung zwischen schröder und
lafontaine waren selbst innerhalb der
spd personalisierte entscheidung und der
dritte bereich ist eben auch etwas was
zwar zunehmend an bedeutung verloren hat
aber das doch immerhin noch ein gewisser
teil der wählerschaft im besten stärker
als im osten
über strukturelle bindungen an die
parteien
verfügt und was wir jetzt in dieser wahl
in der tat
sehr erstaunt wahrnehmen ist wie schnell
doch auch selbst bindungen eines großen
teils der wählerschaft an die union
erschüttert worden ist nachdem wir bei
den land bundestagswahlen davor erlebt
haben wie schnell eigentlich die spd
ihre strukturelle unterstützung verloren
hat und dafür gibt es gründe mehr wir
haben natürlich einfach auch eine
gesellschaftliche veränderung wir müssen
ja sehen es wird ja zum beispiel bei der
programmdiskussion in der union immer
völlig vernachlässigt dass wir ja ein
generation veränderungs verhalten haben
dass wir kohorten haben die heute anders
sich darstellen als zu zeiten von helmut
kohl es sind ja nicht die gleichen
wähler die immer ihre meinung ändern
sondern da sterben große teile der
wählerschaft einfach weg und es kommen
neue hinzu und sie bringen eine andere
gesellschaftliche sozialisation mit und
dadurch verändert sich insgesamt die
grundausrichtung der gesamtheit der
wählerschaft und da müssen parteien
darauf reagieren und wenn sie das nicht
entsprechend machen dann müssen sich
langsam von ihren angestammten
prozentzahlen verabschieden sehen sich
der bürger grosso modo und nach
veränderung oder sehnt er sich eben noch
nicht so große veränderung wir haben in
der deutschen mentalität zumindest in
der breiten bevölkerung immer so eine
position die für ein entschiedenes
sowohl-als-auch ist man hat ganz gerne
den wohlstand und möglichst wenig
veränderung aber schön das klima hätte
man auch ganz gerne und das alles
möglichst
muslim verpackt und deshalb ist es auch
kein wunder ist die parteien wie er
dargestellt worden ist auch da so
fürchterlich vorsichtig sind den
wählerschaften etwas zuzumuten aber das
ist auch kein neues phänomen denken sie
an die die wahlentscheidung
2002 als mit schließung der wahllokale
plötzlich sowohl bei der cdu und csu und
der spd die ganzen einschränkungen in
richtung soziale leistungen
ab 18 uhr 1 zur debatte gestellt wurden
also das sind alles letztlich keine
neuen phänomene aber muss natürlich auch
sehen was ja vorhin gerade diskutiert
worden ist wenn man sagt ja die grünen
sind heute drei und sich nicht mehr so
arg
schafe position zu vertreten wenn sie
stärker werden bullen als die knapp 10%
2017 dann müssen sie natürlich auch
breitere wählerschichten müssen sie
bürgerlicher werden dann müssen sie auch
ihre ökologischen positionen etwas
geschmeidiger gestalten sonst kommen sie
in dieser größenordnung nicht rein das
ist das dilemma der grünen das ist bei
den anderen parteien in anderen unter
anderen rahmenbedingungen ähnlich kann
es am sonntag ein fotofinish geben herr
jung kann das noch mal überraschungen
geben also ob ein fotofinish eine
überraschung ist wage ich zu bezweifeln
das was wir als entwicklung der umfragen
jetzt haben steht da zwar 25 und 22 bei
der spd beziehungsweise der union aber
es ist ja eine
anfrage die 45 tage vor der wahl
durchgeführt worden ist da haben wir
nach wahlabsichten gefragt die wähler
die an der urne abstimmenden werden die
meisten trotz allem sein müssen diese
entscheidung erst am sonntag treffen und
selbst wenn die umfragen muss man ja
auch einfach sehen den ideen sind
statistische fehler bereiche zu diesem
prozentwerten zu denken das heißt
punkte rauf oder runter bei dem beide
liegen und wenn ich jetzt den maximalen
- wert bei der eine maximalen plus wird
dieses fehler intervalls anwende dann
kann letztlich sogar auch jetzt schon
heute mit einer wahl ab sichtbar großer
unsicherheit eventuell sogar die union
vorne sein das muss nicht zu sein und
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist größer wenn
ich zwei punkte vorsprung habe dass es
am schluss auch so bleibt aber kein
mensch kann heute seriös sagen dass
aufgrund dieses befundes einer umfrage
der gewinner in dem sinne der wehr
stärkste partei wird heute schon fest
sie würden auch noch erklären der jungen
das ist keinen großen unterschied macht
die briefwähler auch gleichermaßen
einzubeziehen weil sie das tun und
wollen es dafür auch einen verfahren
gibt für die forschungsgruppe das zu tun
aber sie haben ermittelt noch mal
richtig inhaltlich wichtig dass es keine
konstellation gibt keinen dreier bündnis
gibt was eine mehrheit der deutschen
richtig gut finde und am wenigsten
akzeptiert wäre rot grün rot ja wobei
wir da sagt müssen sie haben es völlig
richtig gesagt so richtig gut finden wir
haben da eine abgestufte ab frage
nämlich ob man ein jedes
koalitionsmodell entweder gut findet
oder schlecht oder ob einem das egal ist
und wenn man sich das anschaut wie viel
prozent der bevölkerung jeweils diese
verschiedenen vorgelegten
koalitionsmodelle gut finden dann kommen
wir nie zu einer mehrheit das heißt also
es muss immer damit eine mehrheitliche
unterstützung für was zustande kommt gut
plus egal zusammengerechnet werden damit
überhaupt zum beispiel eine koalition
aus spd fdp und grünen überhaupt über 50
prozent kommt anzustimmen und das ist
eine nächste schwierigkeit dieser wahl
dass christian lindner sagte es glaube
ich ein kanzler gewählt würde in den 80
prozent der deutschen hochgerechnet
nicht gewählt haben wir sind herr jung
danke für ihre expertise klasse dass sie
heute in der sendung waren und sind
richtungswahlkampf hatten wir plötzlich
plötzlich gingen nicht mehr diese
schwarz-grüne rechnung auf sondern wir
redeten über einen richtungswahlkampf
und einen lagerwahlkampf
noch vor ein paar monaten hätte es für
schwarz grün gereicht von lagerwahlkampf
keine spur ein lagerwahlkampf es nicht
geben weil schon die definition des
lagers sehr schwer fällt doch dann
stürzt die cdu ab jetzt führt die spd
eine ampel wäre möglich oder rot grün
rot die cdu holt die roten socken raus
rot rot grün würde und ihnen eine
katastrophe für und
massenarbeitslosigkeit
abwanderung von industrie auch das linke
lager legt wieder alte platten auf
verspricht wohltaten macht
lagerwahlkampf wir wenden uns gegen jede
weitere anhebung des
renteneintrittsalters wir machen das
nicht mit wir wollen die superreichen
und die profiteure der krise zur kasse
bitten als allererstes den mindestlohn
auf 12 euro anzuheben
also wer bietet mehr es sind die
evergreens der 80er und 90er jahre
zurück glaubt der bürger das noch dass
wir uns in diesem freiheit gegen
sozialismus reichensteuer versus steuer
senken dass wir uns in diesen binären
denken befinden ein teil der bürgerinnen
und bürger ja klar sagt es tatsächlich
bestimmt nicht die mehrheit aber es gibt
kreise ich würde sagen man sagt so
normalerweise bürgerliche mitte wobei
die anderen ja nicht unmöglich sind
bürgerliche mitte hat davor tatsächlich
angst ob es dann geführt ist oder ob
diese angst tatsächlich in den leuten
drin steckt aber diejenigen die sich als
besserverdiener wahrnehmen die machen
sich tatsächlich diese sorgen aber das
ist keine mehrheit der bevölkerung und
dazu kommt natürlich dass ein
nennenswert großer teil der bevölkerung
weiß dass es extrem unwahrscheinlich ist
dass es tatsächlich eine rot grün rote
bundesregierung gibt weil auch olaf
scholz diesen typus von regierung nicht
haben möchte als schreckgespenst ist
jetzt nicht so dramatisch
fragen wir gleich noch mal wie
glaubwürdig ist es das gestern eben noch
über schwarz-grün nachgedacht wurde und
er irgendwie gerade der bayerische
ministerpräsident
noch viel mehr mit den grünen und in der
umarmung jede biene dieses bündnis nach
oben schoss und plötzlich sollen eben
die grünen bestandteil dieses nächsten
riesigen ungemachs für deutschland sein
wie wie glaubwürdig ist es ja so genau
hinschauen mit dafür auf beide farben
nicht so genau scheint also alles sind
auf einmal mit in diesem extremen
bündnis entscheidend drin während man
einerseits bis jetzt mit der spd
koaliert als union gerne mit den grünen
koalieren wird also läuft im grunde die
linkspartei ist der schrecken mit
ungefähr 6 prozent die ist im grunde der
schrecken die beiden anderen können ja
nicht erschreckend sein weil man sie
entweder jetzt braucht oder eventuell in
zukunft braucht aber noch mal ein teil
der bevölkerung schreckt es tatsächlich
das ist im grunde nach wie vor die alte
geschichte und auch diese diese
traditionslinie dass man versucht die
linkspartei noch in die traditionslinie
der pds hineinzuversetzen und
insofern ich würde sagen das trägt
durchaus früchte wenn wir uns den
landtagswahlkampf im jahr 2018 in bayern
anschauen das war das erfolgsrezept noch
ein bisschen besser abzuschneiden auch
diese setzen auf stabilität darauf hofft
man dass das noch ein paar wählerinnen
und wähler tatsächlich bewegt
interessant markus feldenkirchen wir
waren hier gleich zu der geographische
rechten seite markus feldenkirchen haben
wir zitiert eingangs der sendung mit ein
rot grün rotes bündnis hätte die größte
inhaltliche nähe das ist eigentlich
logisch da wären die
koalitionsverhandlungen wahrscheinlich
zwei wochen lang wie und dann werden sie
durch und es könnte ein
regierungsbündnis stehen wie realistisch
ist es in ihren augen dass diese drei
parteien tatsächlich zusammenkommen und
warum waren das sogenannte bürgerliche
lager so davor es ist wahrscheinlich
unrealistisch ich glaube nur alles was
in politische reformen angeht also eine
gemeinsame vorstellung wie es eine
steuer- und haushaltspolitik wie es eine
arbeits und sozialpolitik auch die
klimapolitik auch der umgang mit
minderheiten und deren rechten da sind
sich spd grüne und linke der sehr nah da
würde ich sagen dass das könnten die
unkompliziertesten
koalitionsverhandlungen geben wenn es
die außenpolitik nicht gebe wobei man da
auch sieht dass die linken jetzt schon
angebote gemacht haben dass sie gesagt
hat also passt mal auf wir ticken da
tatsächlich anders was kriegseinsätze
und nato angeht aber wir würden in den
nächsten vier jahren uns zurückhalten
also ich glaube dieses angebot steht da
man könnte zu greifen aber
aus dem aus der angst vor verhetzung
potenzial ist das nicht drin in der
strategie von urlaub und es gibt glaube
ich auch ein
veritables argument gegen rot-rot-grün
das ist nicht dass die inhaltlich so
schlecht zusammenpassen würden sondern
das ist natürlich zu einer form von
polarisierung kommen würde dass sich die
kräfte die drei kräfte die eher links
der mitte stehen bei grünen und spd
schwankt das ja so ein bisschen aber
eher links der mitte stehen unterhaken
und gegen die anderen stehen also in
diesem in unserer konsensdemokratie wo
angela merkel als die programmatischen
der anderen parteien die letzten 16
jahre einfach eingesaugt hat wäre das
mal wieder was anderes und die die dann
angst haben dass es zu größerer
gesellschaftlicher spaltung auch zur
noch größeren aufheizung der debatte
kommt die sagen dass da von
gesellschaftspolitischen mich gar nicht
mehr an ob aus gesellschaftspolitischen
nicht als ich meine das ist doch das
hauptargument der von lucke wird ja
trotzdem
groß wie groß muss die not sein frau
ursel hält oben irgendwie jetzt dieses
rot-rot-grüne schreckgespenster zu
ziehen naja groß ist die not weil das
projekt war ja sowohl bei den grünen als
auch bei der union schwarz grün und vor
drei monaten hätten wir alle auch gesagt
ja das ist die künftige regierung jetzt
liegt plötzlich eine spd vorne eine fdp
wird in der entscheidende rolle bei
einer koalitionsbildung mitspielen da
muss man eine geschichte erzählen und
das schlimme ist ja die union hat keine
geschichte die sie erzählen kann rein
inhaltlich ist dass eine partei ohne
eigenschaften geworden und ich habe
immer bis jetzt auch noch nicht
verstanden genau was was die vision die
idee der union für dieses land und das
ist etwas wo man noch einmal
mobilisieren kann und sich selbst auch
selbst vergewissern kann und ein thema
gefunden hat aber ich glaube
dem der spd und den grünen geht es so
wie der mehrheit der wähler das ist das
bündnis was sie am allerwenigsten wollen
und auch nicht anstreben und manchmal
muss man ja auch die einfach nur
politiker zitieren und es ist ein linker
politik hat ich habe es bei den pats
kollegen gelesen das interview rené
wilke dass der oberbürgermeister von
frankfurt oder
der ist in der linkspartei und der hat
gesagt er rät allen davon ab ein bündnis
mit seiner partei einzugehen weil diese
partei so zerstritten ist meine hilfe
nicht ich sinngemäß nicht in der lage
verantwortung zu übernehmen doch nicht
mal in der rolle der opposition und
lehrende das kann man so stehen lassen
auch die auch die grünen haben ja ein
viel strengeres oder dissonanz ihres
verhältnis zu der linken als die
sozialdemokratie gegebenenfalls und
dennoch ist also vielleicht drehen wir
die frage erst nachher von lucke
was passiert eigentlich
dann an dem wahlsonntag wenn armin
laschet der einen sehr bemerkenswerten
wahlkampf gemacht hat und eben keinen
wirklichen plan hat für dieses land
sondern an ganz vielen stellen das
gefühl hatte er könne einfach in dem
stuhl von frau merkel hineinwachsen was
passiert wenn der am sonntag verliert
was passiert dann in der union
vielleicht ist das ist der gau das ist
der up und das ist das was dann viele
fragen anschließt um auch dann gleich
auf recht aufgebe zweite lager frage zu
kommen wenn diese situation eintritt und
das ist ja nicht unwahrscheinlich dass
ist nicht und können sie gleich
konterkarieren auch das ist der gau der
streit zunächst muss man sich alleine
schon vorstellen warum es eigentlich für
die union jetzt schon geht wenn die
union von 1 und 3 von 33 prozent und
selbst wenn armin laschet noch hauchdünn
die nase vorn hat auf 25 prozent
abstürzt ein ergebnis was vor einem jahr
unvorstellbar gewesen wäre unvorstellbar
die vor einem jahr stand die spd die cdu
csu auf 40 prozent die grünen standen
bei 18 vielleicht 20 die spd stand bei
15 das heißt wir haben in jedem fall
eine solche vernichten niederlage der
cdu csu die gewissermaßen gekrönt
dadurch würde das armin laschet nicht
die nummer eins ist das hätte zur folge
dass die cdu/csu keinerlei interesse
hätte keiner interesse hat sie auch
jetzt schon so deutlich befunden und
klar zum ausdruck gegeben eine schwache
regierung laschet überhaupt mit einem
regierungsauftrag zu versehen weil mit
einer solchen regierung die armin
laschet der übrigens jahr ein das muss
man sich bewusst machen ich will das gar
nicht werten wie ist die diskrepanz
übrigens auch im auftreten und in der
völligen abwertung dieser person nicht
ganz erklärt ich finde dieses lachen er
hat die mal übrigens mit dem lachen fast
verloren alle aller voraussicht nach die
diskrepanz der werte ein olaf scholz bei
70 prozent zustimmung armin laschet bei
30 und 70 prozent missbildungen es wird
in jedem fall ein stück weit ein des
buchs sind immer ein destruktives
misstrauensvotum gegen armin laschet
seien auch selbst wenn er noch
vielleicht auch tun die nase vorn hat
hat er sie nicht vorn wird die csu
sofort sagen wir sind raus und es ist
auch dann dem wähler ein stück
bayerischer müsse wurst machen ist ein
absturz der cdu csu macht vielleicht
zehn prozent und es ist ein anwachsen
der spd um 5% den wir uns kaum vorhätten
vorstellen dass ist auch ein stück weit
eine so massive weder bewegung die die
zahlen werden in diesem fall fast
erschlagen vor allem wenn armin laschet
neben den letzten schritt auch noch
schafft eben noch unter der iss beginnt
ansonsten wird die cdu zählt vor allem
die cdu wird alles tun diesem wahlsieg
noch zu verkaufen der aber auch keiner
ist ist es in jedem verein so damit will
ich sagen dann in dem augenblick ist
sofort die situation die das die csu
sagt wir werden in zwei jahren bayern
gewinnen müssen wir machen opposition
gegen ein und dann wird es richtig
prekär gegen eine regierung die so egal
wie sie geführt wird nur eine ampel
seien bei rot-rot-grün ich will dass man
als einzige sagen es gibt ja kein lager
wir haben davor diese sendung gemeinsam
gesehen es gibt bei karl marx der schöne
begriff meint es gibt den begriff der
klasse an sich und für sich die klasse
an sich ist die die sich einfach
arithmetischer die die klasse ist da und
hier haben wir plötzlich eine
arithmetische situation ist kommen drei
parteien zähle risch also arithmetisch
summarisch über die erforderlichen
prozent oder mehr aber es hat nie eine
bewusstsein dieser drei parteien in den
letzten jahr vier jahren genug ein
gespräch zwischen den spitzenkandidaten
alles reine aversion es gibt also gar
kein verständnis dafür dass ist eine
koalition für sich also einen kleinen
lager oder einen einen koalitions
bewusstsein gebe damit will ich sagen
dass scheidet aus dann muss es in dem
augenblick scholz richten und das alle
eine wird in dieser neuen konstellation
für ihn so schwierig werden das wird die
lage sein wenn laschet wirklich verliert
die müssen ganz kurz noch mal nachfragen
diejenigen die sich jetzt in der cdu
frau mensch
volker bouffier wolfgang schäuble so
sehr stark gemacht habe für armin
laschet ihn eigentlich überhaupt möglich
gemacht haben was wird mit denen
passieren wir haben wir sehen ja schon
dass die in bedrängnis geraten also
dieser seitenhieb dieser massive
seitenhieb von wolfgang schäuble gegen
gegen angela merkel das war ja im grunde
schon die rückzugs position und die
schuldzuweisung position nach dem motto
ich bin es nicht und ich war nicht
schuld an dieser mal seinen
parteivorsitz er hat im grunde ja die
schuld von sich gewiesen damit das thema
verlagert obwohl schäuble ja laschet
ganz massiv unterstützt hat und im
grunde versucht hat und erfolgreich
versucht hat zu verhindern also da wird
es eine große debatte geben die brodelt
garantiert jetzt schon wer hat das
eigentlich vermasselt und im grunde ja
dann auch die frage welche konsequenzen
zieht eigentlich eine partei raus mit
hinblick und unter hinblick darauf wie
kommt man eigentlich zu
kanzlerkandidaten wie kommt man zum
spitzenpersonal und diese frage sind
eigentlich die gremien wie laschet es
wollte und ein teil der cdu oder wie
stark welche rolle spielt eigentlich die
basis eine öffentliche meinung wie es
das argument war und das wird natürlich
die cdu ganz massiv beschäftigt ein
stoiber hat nun wiederum wolfgang
schäuble schon kritisiert und der
generalsekretär blume spricht schon vor
der wahl von einer erneuerung die es in
der union bräuchte also wir malen uns
alle aus dass das keine schöne zeit wird
für die union wenn armin laschet nicht
nur nicht die spd zahlen erreicht
sondern sogar auf platz zwei rangiert
oder ist realistisch dass er noch mal
dann auch neue bündnis ideen und
wenn sie mal muss man sagen wer sich mit
der karriere von armin laschet
beschäftigte sollte vorsichtig sein team
frühzeitig abzuschreiben sollte die
union tatsächlich hinter der spd landen
dann ist das aus meiner sicht alles
andere als ein gaudi hell von dunkel
gesagt hat sondern
demokratie die lebt vom wechsel und
wunderbar wenn nach 16 jahren es auch
die möglichkeit gibt es hatte ja seine
ungefähr ist eine andere
aber
okay aber das ist dann vielleicht für
die karrierepläne von armin laschet aber
ehrlich gesagt hat die union doch nach
16 jahren angela merkel dieser
systematischen programm losigkeit
dieses auch nicht zulassen dass andere
köpfe stark und präsent werden hat sie
einfach ein strukturelles problem
und jeder partei täte dann eine
opposition zeit auch mal gut zur
selbstfindung zu selbstvergewisserung
selbst eine und vielleicht lernt die
union dann der auch mal dass nur zu
sagen na ja wir machen es irgendwie hat
besser im kanzleramt aber wissen gar
nicht wofür dass das so von der
grundidee einer partei nicht mehr so
mich mal so zeitgemäß das ist aber nur
der drauf gegeben ist uns ja schon mal
die frage stellen und ich glaube es
werden noch ganz andere
auseinandersetzung geführt werden wie es
kommen konnte dass eine partei wie die
cdu die bei 40 stand eine spd die bei 14
stand regelrecht wieder erweckt hat es
ist ja ganz bemerkenswert dass allein
die tatsache dass man einen
spitzenkandidaten aufgeboten hat nahm
als amina und verdrängung des markus
söder der heute noch um längen besser
steht und damit dass das eigentlich
verrückte sich den größten gegner von
armin laschet eingehandelt hat denn ein
markus söder zum schwesterpartei führer
zu haben in der konstellation ist
schlimmer als ein feind zu haben söder
hat in einer weise eine rachefeldzug
gegen die haben für heute auch wieder
erlebt der kaum ein einziges gutes wort
an laschet gelassen hat
es ist eine absolute selbst tracks
destruktion einer volkspartei gewesen
die sich die ganze zeit und das war ja
der grund warum schäuble überhaupt laut
schätzung durch geprägt ständig noch im
glauben denke wir können gegen diese spd
gar nicht wenn das stoppen übrigens auch
alle beobachter wir haben doch keiner
von uns irgendwie die annahme gehabt
dass diese spd auf diesen diesen
höhenflug gehen können und das ist ja
das ist ein strukturelles problem und
ich erwarte auch natürlich das souveräne
figuren auch die frage einmal darauf
werfen was ist die schuld von markus
söder was ist ein herr seehofer hat ihn
bald in bälde freie hand der kann sich
äußern und die frage aufwerfen denn so
da wird auch ein ein bemerkenswertes
ergebnis in bayern zu vertreten haben
das nicht dem entspricht also fast eine
million steine solche lösung ich will
meinen letzten letzten gedanken richtig
es ist kein nur cdu csu wir werden es
erleben es ist nicht nur ein cdu/csu
problem wenn eine letzte die letzte
volkspartei die wir hatten mit spd ist
eine lädierte partei mag sein dass sie
wieder jetzt zu kräften kommen kann aber
wenn die plötzlich auf unter 30 prozent
für unter 25 prozent abstürzen werden
wir daraus konstellation probleme
bekommen eine normale schwarz-grüne
konstellation diese noch vor einem jahr
der normalfall gewesen wäre wäre vielen
veränderungs notwendigkeiten in diesem
lande wahrscheinlich weit zuträglicher
gewesen als eine dreier konstellation
wie das jetzt kriegen und deswegen ist
es ein auch ein problem für die für die
statik dieses systems und das ist ein
demokratieproblem was erstmal gelöst
wären das dann auch eine solche
regierung schaffen kann ich versuche es
noch mal ein bisschen zu ordnen
frauenfeld wir wollten ja uns auch nach
diesen riesigen
sozialen aufgaben noch mal ganz ganz
kurz oder wollten die uns noch mal ganz
kurz anschauen die vor deutschland
liegen es muss ein rentensystem erneuert
werden es müssen die steuern in der
systematik verändert werden es gilt eben
die bürokratie zu bekämpfen wir wollten
das ist nicht mehr sechs jahre dauert
bis das windrad und so und auch da merkt
man dass selbst die sozialdemokratie
eben mit dem versprechen dass es eine
vermögenssteuer gibt natürlich auch
einen betrag geldes ausruf der am ende
nicht reichen wird wenn ich mieten
bezahlbar machen möchte die rente
bezahlbar machen möchte hat viele
sanktionen absenken will und vieles
andere mehr also auch da hat man das
gefühl wird wieder nicht adäquat zur
größe der aufgabe einen plan angeboten
ja also die vermögenssteuer wird dieses
land nicht retten und die
vermögenssteuer wird auch gar nicht
aufkommen das ist symbolpolitik und in
diesem fall ist sie sogar nur ein symbol
im wahlprogramm weil die umsetzbarkeit
dieser steuer das ist ein bürokratisches
monster was mannschaft der ertrag steht
in keinerlei verhältnis zum aufwand wenn
man sich in den parteien umhört weder
die spd oder
weite teile der spd wollen diese steuer
und bei den grünen auch nicht
was aber grundsätzlich auch es wird ja
auch bei der rente also ich finde es
fast eine frechheit von olaf scholz dass
eine rentengarantie de abend gibt also
das ist der blüten der 80er die rente
ist sicher wie er das sagen und zu sagen
kann es werden jetzt schon 100
milliarden euro im jahr aus dem
bundeshaushalt in dieses rentensystem
gepumpt die baby boomer gehen jetzt erst
in rente riester rente hat versagt das
ist da eine elementare reformen geben
muss eine veränderung dieses systems ist
so klar da darüber gibt es kein wort man
will ein bisschen was eine alternative
zur riester-rente schafften
ja eine unser steuersystem muss man ran
die eigentliche ungerechtigkeit in
diesem steuersystem ist doch dass ein
facharbeiter mit einem einkommen ab
55.000 euro bin ich spitzen steuerzahler
das war ein vergehen dann kommen nicht
mehr üben über die northeimer
progression dann kommt die inflation da
wird fast gar nicht in diesem wahlkampf
darüber gesprochen und das belastet alle
alle durch alle einkommensschichten
hindurch ist das eine belastung markus
söder hat immerhin die inflation jetzt
doch noch einmal aufgegriffen und gesagt
dass das eine kalte enteignung ist und
initiativen jetzt vorgeschlagen er kann
wir haben aber kann ich überall raus man
kann ja bei einer einzelmaßnahme wie die
vermögenssteuer reden ich glaube ganz so
unsinnig ist sie nicht wenn sie von
diversen instituten oder auch dem iwf
vorgeschlagen wird aber okay sie tun wir
die mal beiseite anleihen ländern seien
die angesichts der größe der
finanzierungs aufgaben die wir haben
plus all dem was wir aus der korona zeit
an belaste mitschleppen dann noch
steuersenkungen versprechen und nicht
erklären wo die zusätzlichen einnahmen
her kommen solche parteien gibt es ja
auch ich finde das ist der lage nicht
angemessen da ist es nicht
steuererhöhungen sind ja bei niemandem
populär muss man sagen und wenn man da
anfangs sei okay
unser konzept würde bedeuten zu einer
halbwegs seriöse gegenfinanzierung
wir machen weitere schulden wir erhöhen
den
spitzensteuersatz und
gucken auch bei der erbschaftssteuer
unter vermögenssteuer ob wir die nicht
höher erhöhen oder einzuführen das ist
erst mal mutig weil das finden viele
nicht toll aber ich sage mir dieser mut
fehlt mir eigentlich zusage der cdu weil
die rechenoperation haben wir alle
nennen nicht verstanden wie man die
steuern senken will und gleichzeitig
irgendwie die schulden senken will und
noch die schuldenbremse einhalten aber
das will olaf scholz auch also wir
merken das ist ein nächster weiterer
großer sack in dem dem bürger
offensichtlich jetzt im wahlkampf eine
menge erzählt wird und dann gibt es
abstufungen von unwahrheiten die zum
beispiel wird der demografische wandel
wird komplett ausgespart wird nicht
thematisiert spielt ein bisschen thema
und der rolle mit blick auf klimapolitik
dass es da ja junge leute gibt die
interessen haben die nicht angemessen
repräsentiert werden dass man aber diese
jungen leute im grunde bei der
rentenpolitik anlügt dass man mit blick
auf
21% über 70-jährige im grunde eine
politik für die alten macht aber
verschweigt dass diese renten
zusammenlegen und her das wird schlicht
ergreifend ausgeklammert ich gebe ihnen
recht das ist von den sozialdemokraten
meines erachtens treffliches lücken